Hey, everybody, what's happening?
Welcome to the Shadow Intensive.
Let me find your comments over here. How's everybody doing?
We're running a little bit late here today.
Uh, I had an issue, uh, a little while ago.
I think we're good now. I, let me find the chat.
Yes, I am feeling, I keep saying I feel better today.
I know I sound the same, but I do feel better.
Um, so yeah, we're gonna keep, uh, pushing forward.
Um, I'm gonna tell you, I, I woke up, uh, with a great, uh,
uh, how many of you had a, a greeting this morning?
Uh, I had an amazing greeting here in my telegram.
Uh, and this is what it's, well, this is what I woke up to.
I'll show you on the screen too.
Um, I basically woke up to Titanium Health Check Green,
which means it goes and checks all of our APIs,
make sure it gets a response,
which means all of our softwares on.
Uh, and then I gave it a list
of 20 different domains yesterday,
and I said, every single day, I want you
to go check on these domains.
Some of 'em are C names, some of 'em are from quiz forma,
from course Sprout, from Letterman, from the directory.
Just every little thing I could think of
to pinpoint could something be wrong.
Uh, it gave me a green check mark there too.
So, titanium Health Check was great.
Fresh Desk report, uh, it said there's two urgent tickets,
there's four new tickets.
Uh, everything was good there.
Uh, gave me my ad stats, gave me my ad stats for the month,
which isn't great.
Uh, but that's a topic for another day.
Uh, today, the, um, uh,
lead developer on Letterman, I realized something.
I'm like, man, how incredible would it be to wake up
and know that there was 35 local newsletters sent out
successfully this morning,
and there was one that had a problem.
And then we could reach out
and say, Hey, was there a problem with SMTP?
Was it with Mel? What is it?
So really be thinking about that morning alert
and what can it do?
Maybe it's not internally in your
own software like it is for us.
This is such, um, this is such a blessing for me
to wake up knowing that everything's online.
And I get that check three times a day, by the way, uh,
it is such a blessing for me, knowing
that everything is good, right?
Um, and then, uh,
there's something else that we're gonna be doing.
Uh, Ahad is on the call.
He's one of my developers, been with me for a long time.
We have a calendar functionality inside of Letterman.
Now, even though I don't encourage, or not Letterman,
but gc, even though I don't encourage you guys
to connect your Google calendar, I got to thinking,
I'm like, but if you got appointments coming in
through your appointment system, hey,
we can tell you about those.
We can tell you about those. It's using the same API key.
So we're gonna pull the, uh, API endpoints.
It'll tell you any appointments
you have for the day as well.
'cause I know a lot of people are using
our appointment system.
Okay? So really be thinking about that.
What do you need to know every morning?
What videos are you watching?
Like for us on YouTube,
obviously we're watching a lot on Open Claw ai.
What do you need to monitor, right?
What can you set up for your clients that they need
to monitor, right?
Uh, maybe there's keyword trends out there.
Maybe you're watching stocks.
Maybe you're watching the, I used to look at the price
of Bitcoin every day.
I don't do that no more, right?
Whatever it is, you need to be alerted for the day
to have a more effective day.
Guys really be thinking about that.
And I'll get that report and I'll be like, Hey, you forgot
to include the support desk.
I'll be like, okay, I'll, I'll add that next time.
I'll be like, can you just go ahead
and gimme your morning brief again?
And, okay, memorize that. Does that make sense?
How many of you're getting a morning brief?
Type in the chat. Let me know
who here is getting a morning brief.
Um, so here's what we're gonna do right away.
Uh, let me just check. Bne, did you get the email out today?
Our attendance is low on this call. Yeah, I it's out. Why?
Okay. Did it go out late?
Uh, no. Okay. We are live on the call.
This is gonna be a really, really good call.
So I wanna make sure I get everybody here.
Uh, this is what we have planned today.
Uh, does anybody wanna learn how to deploy, uh, software,
little software apps today and,
and get them online where you can actually open up a link?
Uh, does anybody wanna be able to do that? Yeah. Okay.
We're gonna do that today. Uh, I'm gonna give you a, uh,
power command that we created called the Second Brain.
Um, and what this is gonna do is it's gonna be able
to store ideas, whatever else,
and explore different ideas, okay?
Um, so, uh, it's kind of cool
because I've talked a lot about how you gotta get things,
you know, on paper, you gotta get
'em in Trello or whatever else.
Well, now I used to be able to send an audio file
and say, Hey, do me a favor, right?
Record this, add this to the second brain.
Um, and it's just a different memory base,
but it has, uh, a different command for what it's supposed
to do with that, right?
Um, we're gonna get into that one,
and then I'm gonna give you, uh, one more, uh,
power command today as well.
And what I'll do is, uh,
if somebody can give me the Google Doc from yesterday,
I'll add them to the Google Doc.
But does anybody have that doc handy?
Let me see if I can pull that up.
Uh, I forgot to add that resource to the members area.
I will do that today. Uh, where is that Google Doc?
Hold on a second. Let me open that Google Doc.
If anybody has that link from yesterday,
please save me the trouble.
I should have just given it to my open
claw, but I wasn't thinking.
There. There we go. All right, thank you, Craig.
So if I go ahead and share my screen, I just wanna make sure
that you guys are keeping up.
So yesterday I gave you, uh, the API skills builder.
And if you notice with all of these commands, ask chat,
GPD may get personalized to your business first.
So I gave you the API skill builder.
We're gonna use that again today with Sprout, right?
I said pace this into, uh, chat BT
and replace it with your API doc URL.
And then it gives you this big long command.
You put that into your open clot
and it learns your API doc very, very well.
Okay? That was the first one.
Next, I taught you how to take your open claw
and go from, um, uh, being reactive
to proactive instead of you telling open claw what to do.
How many of you guys have started changing it around?
And you've started asking open claw,
what do you think we should do with this?
So, for instance, I jumped in there yesterday
after I was really, really frustrated,
and I said, Hey, can you help me out?
I am waiting on my server admins to set up all
of these notifications.
If there's a problem with the server, something else,
is there something we can do so
that I get notified every morning that things are okay?
And it pinpointed two things.
It said, sure, I can go ahead
and tap into your API keys
that you've given me on all of your platforms.
And that is a good indicator. Everything's online.
I was like, wow. Didn't think of that.
And the second thing is, you use a lot of c names and,
and, um, custom domains and stuff like that.
So we can take a list of those
and I can check those every single day.
And then I can let you know if both those things are okay.
And we'll call that the titanium health check. Perfect.
Set that up for me. Done. Add it to your morning brief.
Does that make sense? Ask it.
What do you think we should do, guys?
That's how it's going to, uh, start to receive.
You're, you're passing the torch.
You're starting to go down the direction of being a CEO.
Don't tell it what to do. Always. Okay? Train it. Yes.
So it becomes familiar with you,
but start to change the wording you're using.
What do you think we should do here?
Do you have any ideas here? Right?
What are your thoughts on this? Okay.
Does everybody get that? Type in the chat?
Let me know if you're getting that. Yeah,
because we want to be more proactive.
Remember guys, I know it's gonna sound crazy.
I know, you know, Arnold Schwarzenegger,
all the freaking movies and everything else,
but we want this thing controlling us.
We wanna make this thing a CEO,
and we want this thing to identify opportunities.
Look for loopholes, right?
Find those obstacles, get us past those things.
So we're more productive, we're more effective,
we have more time, uh, we have more freedom,
and we're able to make more money
and without having to have a lot of staff
and everything else, right?
And these are all talks that I'm having
with my team, my developers.
I'm like, look, man, this thing's gonna replace a lot
of what's happening in the world today with coding, uh,
with VA tasks and everything else.
I don't wanna lose you guys.
So I need you to start adapting different roles.
I need you to become, start becoming super in
your role, right?
Because it's gonna be harder and harder
and harder to maintain staff members.
Okay? So these are conversations I'm having too. Okay?
So this open claw autonomous operator directive takes you
from going, uh, passive
or takes you from going reactive to, um,
yeah, I, I didn't know it was that long, right?
So we go from reactive to proactive. Okay? So there we go.
I'm gonna give you more of these today.
I'm gonna put 'em in the chat. Did
anybody type in the chat here?
Did anybody go load these commands yesterday?
It's a simple copy and paste. Did anybody do that yesterday?
Let me see. And if you did,
is it starting to, uh, take a different role?
Is it starting to take a different role?
Now, guys, I'm gonna tell you something, man.
Um, if you hop on the call
and I lay these things out for you,
and all you have to do is come over here
and go just like this, copy
and paste it into your, uh, your telegram
or, um, you know,
if you're on the VPS into your control panel.
If you're not doing that, you need
to do this in a timely fashion.
Does that make sense? You can't just take all these things
at once and paste them in there.
There's a reason why we're doing these things a day apart.
I I want you to go and, and paste that
and have some conversations with it.
It, it learns, it starts to adapt to that.
And then once it's got that in motion,
then we give it the next prompt.
Then we give it the next command.
You can't just come in here and grab all these at once
and paste them all at once.
You are gonna create a cluster. All right?
I've got a lot of these things to give you.
So don't get behind on that. Can y'all type the chat?
Let me know that you understand that.
Uh, also, as always, if you're having problems connecting,
I know somebody tried to connect to a different, uh,
model yesterday and they broke it.
Just put your hand up. They can get you fixed. Okay?
But try, try to stay up with this guys.
This isn't even a class where you need
to watch the replays, blah, blah, blah.
The replays are there, but just
try to keep up with the class.
You know, we're doing simple things.
We're doing like two or three things each
class actually do it.
Don't say to yourself, I'll watch a replay and do it later.
No, no, no. Just do it. Just do it now. Okay.
So here's what we're gonna do.
Uh, you can see I've been going back and forth here.
I I've been learning a lot about its abilities.
It was pretty interesting.
Um, you guys could still see my screen, right? Chi?
Yeah. We're seeing telegram.
Yeah. Okay. So, um, just to kinda give you guys an idea,
uh, I gave it a name sheet, uh, API yesterday
and I said I want to be alerted, uh,
if there's ever a domain that's going
to expire within seven days.
So just every single day,
give me a green check mark, you're good.
And if there's one that's gonna expire, uh, guys,
I've lost a lot of domains.
Um, you know,
'cause we didn't have it set up on Autorenew or whatever.
Not no more. I just wanna be notified. Okay?
So these are all domains.
And then, uh, name chief has made some changes
with their C name, and we have found that there's some
of our domains that, uh, are having trouble.
And so we're getting 'em all over to CloudFlare.
So I said, Hey, do me a favor.
Go into my pop links
or go into my mint bird, uh, find all the personal domains
that I've added in there, and then tell me out of those, uh,
which ones are or aren't on name cheap.
So it went through and we did all that.
And then I said, okay,
so you could see it was comparing name cheap versus
what was in our software.
Uh, and then I said, uh,
somewhere here, these are the compares.
It was doing, it was a little confusing at
first, somewhere here.
I said, so out of those,
tell me which ones are having problems.
And so it went and checked the links
and it said, Hey, this one was
timed out, this one, this one.
So we went, we moved 'em all
to CloudFlare and now we're good.
So what I was telling you guys yesterday,
I think it's a good check for you all of your main domains.
It could be a, a survey, it could be, uh, your newsletter,
it could be, uh, any funnels that you have,
any webinars signed up that you have, any of those links.
Take that URL that, that URL list, give it to your open claw
and say, Hey, check this every single day.
Let me know in the morning brief that my links are all good.
Does that make sense? And hopefully you guys are not dealing
with 300 something links in seven different
API keys and everything else.
Like we are. So really be thinking about those things
that are important in your business.
Okay? Um, what we'll get into tomorrow is,
and I might get Matt Garrett's help for this, is making sure
that we send out an email every single day
and having that thing help you craft that email every day.
If we just give it an idea,
it can give us some ideas, what we can write about.
It can go look at the stats. Um, am I not pinned right now?
Gee, can you pin me please? Let's see. There we go.
Okay. Uh, I have my video off. It can look at the stats.
It can say, Hey, your email yesterday, you know,
you got a 60% open rate on it.
We got, uh, you know, um, I don't know,
a 12% click through rate.
Whatever's good today. Uh,
why don't we write another email like that?
Well, you got some more hooks.
Yeah, let's come up with the, okay, cool. Write it. Boom.
Yeah, that looks good. Just add this,
make sure that link goes there.
Boom. Send it every day. Guys. Does that make sense?
That's a total game changer for you.
'cause if you're writing email every single
day, everything changes.
Is that true, Matt? One email a day
keeps the bill collectors away.
Yeah. And the IRS
and everything else, guys.
I'm not one of the talk, man.
I have, Karthik called me out at my event three years ago
and he said, that dude right there
that brought me in the business when I was making $2 an hour
has left nearly $20 million on the table
because he does not send out email.
He called me on it in front of everybody
and he was right and he was right.
Guys, I hate email. Do you know?
I would rather hang out here, here with you
for two hours than take 10 minutes and write a simple email.
I hate email. I'm sorry. I do. I just don't like it.
I'm not good at it. I, and I failed English in school.
I failed grammar. I just, I'm not, I'm good at coming up
with angles and objectives and hooks and,
but I'm not good at writing it.
So if this thing can assist me with that
and can hold me accountable, like Matt, when he goes
to lay down on the couch
and it's like, Hey, you better get your butt back up
your half hour's over.
It can nag me all day long until it sees that email go out.
Do you understand the things you know that have
to happen in your business
that you know you're gonna procrastinate with?
You know, you're gonna find every excuse in the book not
to do this thing can nag you all day
long until it gets done.
'cause it can think about it, guys.
And I just came up with this, by the way.
There can be Aron job that keeps checking into GC
to make sure that there's an email sent out, right?
If you're not using gc, that's okay.
I have a feeling AWeber get response, whatever.
Go high level. I have a feeling there.
APIs, you can probably, it can probably go check
to see if you sent out an email today
and get your stats as well.
It would make sense, right?
So this thing's gonna hold you accountable.
We discovered that the other day with Matt, right?
So, uh, yes, it, it can alert you, give
that warm fuzzy feeling, yes, it can assist you, uh,
with the stuff that you need to be a part of.
Yes, it can replace, uh, your whole entire team and,
and what they are doing, right?
Um, but on top of that, yeah,
it can also be an accountability partner.
Okay? So, uh, today we're gonna dive back into the APIs.
Uh, we had some endpoints created last night,
um, with Course Sprout.
This is a very, very important one.
I am bound and determined to prove
that I can take a simple video like I'm doing now
and throw it into a Dropbox folder, a Google Drive folder,
or even a, a a Vimeo folder.
I probably wouldn't do Google Drive
'cause it's gonna have access to your Gmail.
Um, I would not give it access to that.
But, uh, for me, I'll just take all those videos and go plop
and drop 'em right into Vimeo.
And this thing has access to Vimeo, as you saw yesterday.
I have a feeling that we can train it to go into that folder
and build out the whole entire course, yes or no.
How many of you believe that have to be true?
How many of you can see that based on
what you saw yesterday?
Yeah. I, I think that's true.
I've had a lot of people reaching out to me on the side
and they say, man, uh, I don't comment or anything,
but just let you know I'm watching.
You're one of the only guys
that's actually out there doing things, not just saying
how great Open Claw is and how you can use this model
and do this and that you're actually doing
these things, right?
So I think that this is a great opportunity for us.
So here's what we're gonna do.
Uh, we're gonna give you guys a recap.
Uh, we're gonna do exactly what I asked you guys to do.
Um, and so I'm gonna start over, uh,
or I'll, I'll kick it off and then I'll let g uh, uh,
help me when I need it.
Uh, but let me see if I can find, uh, that link
that somebody gave me.
Where is that? There we go.
Alright, so here's what we're gonna do.
We are going to go ahead
and grab this, uh, prompt right here.
Our API skill builder.
I'm gonna go ahead and copy this real fast, okay?
There we go. And, uh, we are gonna come over here.
I'm gonna do a new instance of Chad GPT. Okay?
So, 'cause I, I got stuff loaded for you guys
that I've been working on for you guys today.
All right? So we, we have these things today,
but for right now, let me see if I can open up
that new instance.
Chad, GPT. All right.
So I'm just gonna go ahead and paste this, just like
that, okay?
And then I'm gonna go ahead
and replace the, um, can you gimme the URLG to the, um,
the API for course route?
You put that in the chat for me
and just let me know if you're doing that
or I'll go hunt it myself.
Okay? I'm getting you that.
Perfect. Okay, there we go. I got it.
Did it change at all or didn't change, right?
No, it can still use the same link. Yeah.
Okay. So here we go. Now, guys, in all fairness,
I think I have already done something
with Core Sprout in here,
but this is what I want you guys to do.
So here's the, here's the prompt, okay?
This is a prompt, right?
And you're gonna replace it with your API doc.
We're gonna hit return. I'm not gonna spend a lot
of time on this 'cause we did this yesterday,
but I think this is pretty phenomenal.
Okay? So it's gonna go through,
it's gonna look at the API docs
and it's gonna go give us this amazing command
that we are going to give to Open Claw.
So that Open Claw does not get all confused on the API docs
and a lot of back and forth and everything else, right?
So here we go. Let's wait for it to spit that out.
All right, I'm building the Taylor prompt with the base URL.
It looks like there are 16 endpoints, okay? Good.
Past this into open claw
as your universal API ingest prompt.
I love it. How many of you guys are liking this?
So here it is right here, right?
Any API doc, you have, you do this.
So we're gonna go ahead and copy this,
and this is what we are going to give
to Open Claw.
Now, you don't have to understand any of this stuff, a lot
of techy stuff, but just understand it's going
to explore it, it's going to test it, uh, it's gonna verify
and it's gonna repeat back to you,
and it's going to, uh, confirm
that everything is verified and good.
Okay? So, and this one's a big one. That's okay.
Do I want to go down here to the artifacts too?
GI don't think I need to do I
Oh, it's giving you a lot of stuff.
Um,
I've never seen it give us as much.
I'm gonna stop up here. Okay, good.
You must not proceed to final artifact until,
uh, is that fine?
Yeah, I think that should be good.
I don't know why it's creating all this artifacts.
Now this is, is this a new chat
or did you do it on the existing one?
No, it's a new chat. Lemme try something else.
Uh, I don't know my login, but I'm gonna go ahead and,
and try to do this real quick too, guys.
Uh, lemme go ahead and try to do this with, um,
perplexity for a minute.
So lemme see if I can find, uh, where is this guy here?
Okay, so let's try this one more time.
So I'm gonna do this with perplexity
and, uh, let me go ahead and,
and, uh, we'll put our API doc here.
Let's see what Perplexity does. Okay?
And we'll just like that, boom.
You really can't get this wrong, guys, right?
You really can't get it wrong. Okay?
So let's go ahead and do this. Here we go.
All right, let's see what perplexity gives us. All right?
Uh, use the following command. And Justin, you're an API.
Okay? So go through here, we'll go
through here, we'll go down here.
All right. Authenticity, schema,
model extraction, skill wrapper.
I want the skill wrapper for sure. Right? Let's see.
Test proof, command generation, coding, and efficiency.
Man, that one's long too. That's okay.
We're gonna go with this.
And do I need this bottom part? I don't, right?
Okay, so let's go ahead and copy this,
and we're gonna go ahead and put this into Telegram.
Okay? So here we go. I'm gonna go ahead and paste this.
Boom, there we go.
And we can watch up here at the top. It is typing. Okay?
Uh, and hopefully it does have the
A-P-I-U-R-L in there, right?
So again, man, that one's long.
We might do something to that, uh, prompt G.
So it's not as long. Maybe, I don't know,
we can go into the doc and update form, right?
Yeah. Okay.
So it's typing up here. All right.
If we were looking at it from inside the VPS,
the box would be flashing,
but I'm trying to get to the point
where you guys are not working inside your VPS.
Does that make sense? How many
of you have started working from Telegram?
Anybody?
You ain't gonna break it as much if you're in
Telegram, right?
Okay. So it's typing.
And what it's doing is it's learning about the core Sprout,
API right now,
all right?
Yep. You can do your onboarding.
Is there anybody that hasn't done their onboarding yet?
Now I watch it in both places.
I watch it, uh,
I watch it here on my phone.
Uh, I'll tell you this much, guys, for my business,
I always have Zoom, uh,
open on my phone on the desktop, on, on right here.
Like, I always have Zoom open so I can hear from my team.
And I always have Telegram open.
And then I monitor WhatsApp too, right?
Uh, and that way I don't have
to have this stuff up on the screen.
Normally this stuff would not be on the screen, right?
Uh, okay, so this'll go through,
yeah, and it's gonna do a lot of stuff that, uh,
you guys don't even need to know about.
But what we're looking for is, uh, the result
that it's going to produce.
Now, while it's doing that, let me explain
what our goal is today over here, uh, inside
of Sprout and g.
Do we have any concerns with, uh, do we have any concerns
with the Airtable at all today?
Uh, not the new ones, no.
Okay. So if I look at this here,
and let me look at this from, uh, uh, I'll,
I'll look at this from the Entourage perspective.
Uh, if we look at our, uh, course area over here, how many
of you would learn, love to learn how
to do this time to chat.
Let me know what, what is the magic?
How come, how come Chad can do this over and over and over
and over and over and over and over and over and over.
And how come he can blow this up and,
and bring in all these comments over here and,
and have all these goals coming in
and all these, how,
how in the heck does he keep doing this over and over
and over and over, right?
Well, I think that we're gonna be able to do,
have the same exact effect with Open Claw.
Now, it's up to you if you're gonna make this an AI video.
I will never, ever do that.
That will always be me in that video.
Um, and I'll do, uh, uh, something
for Sprout here, probably.
Well, after we get through all this open claw stuff,
we'll, we'll circle back around.
I'll show you some of the
secrets that we're doing over here.
Um, but I'm gonna break down in a very simplified manner,
uh, what is making this work, uh, so
that you guys understand this, okay?
But first, let's come over here
starting full Course Brow, API ingestion.
This will take a few minutes. Found existing
skill with nine Endpoint.
Let's use browser to check
for additional endpoints in live Docs.
Found seven new endpoints, not in the current skill.
Updating now course brow, API ingestion, complete courses
for memberships.
Three members, four lessons.
One gamification, one API retrieval three.
So these are called end points, okay?
New capabilities unlocked.
I can create courses via API and create pods
and memberships via a PII can create lessons
with video linking.
I can create gamification goals,
and I can retrieve badges, goals and community topics.
Can you show me a list of the courses
I have in that account?
All right, so it already has an API key.
Let's see if it can access our courses.
And by the way, what I'm showing you right now, yeah,
we're starting with Course Sprout,
but I have a feeling this will be, uh,
the way all course platforms go soon
as they catch on what we're doing.
I think you'll see it with school.
I think you'll see it with Teachable.
I think you'll see it with, uh, what's the other ones?
Uh, I can't even think of it now. But here's your course.
Proud courses. So it clearly is inside of our platform.
Are you guys seeing this right now? It's in our account.
It's in our account.
Okay, so this is where we're gonna start.
We're gonna start out with the MVP.
Alright, so what is the MVP?
Well, let me explain this really quick,
if you don't know, okay?
I'm inside of a, as a mastermind member,
obviously they have a lot more than, uh, you guys might have
as, as just a free member, okay?
Um, and that's not you guys on the call,
but I'm just saying that there was free
members, which there are.
Uh, but this is called a course.
And right now I'm inside of a pod.
So this pod has all of these courses.
If I go inside the course, these are lessons, well,
actually, these are, I'm sorry, these are chapters.
And then if I were to open up this chapter, uh,
which you guys should be doing, there are lessons, okay?
Is everybody seeing this right now? Type in the chat.
Let me know if you're seeing this. Okay?
So first of all,
I don't know if it can create a chapter, but that's okay.
We're gonna start out with the MVP here. Okay?
So let's go open up a lesson.
So first of all, this is a lesson.
This lesson has a title, it has a description.
If we open this up, it has a video. So we have a video.
This is called a long description,
and this is called a goal block.
Okay? Is there anybody that likes the way
that we do our training?
Does anybody love going through this stuff? Anybody at all?
Is it good? Is it good?
Having the, the goal block where, where it detail stuff, uh,
I'm gonna give you guys the secret,
and this is how I know this can be done, okay?
Most of this stuff is created with chat.
GPTI give it a little bit of a guide,
but I ask it to follow a certain format,
and then I go through and I link it so I know
that Claude can build out these goals.
Okay? So here's my goal.
We now know that if this lives on Vimeo,
it can grab the transcript.
If it can grab the transcript,
and it can create the headline, the sub headline,
the post headline for our pages,
then why can't it look at the transcript
and create our short description, our
long description, if there was one,
and our goal block on a scale
of one outta 10, how many
of you're understanding this right now?
Because if it can do that,
and I'm sure it can, if it can do that, that means
that I can go
and shoot 10 of these videos real quick, not focused on
creating the lesson, loading it here, grabbing the URL,
creating the description, creating the goal block.
All I do is create the 10 videos, drop it into Vimeo,
and say, go.
And it's trained on building the course.
Now, who would actually go out there
and start creating content?
When you start cracking the code to things,
you start creating your own system, process, method,
strategy, secret formula, which by the way, is
what this whole open cloth thing is right now.
Who would start cracking the code?
Who would actually start doing that?
Who would start building an audience?
Because guys, let me remind you
of one thing that's very important.
No matter what we discover, no matter what AI adds no one,
well, what discoveries there are,
you still gotta have something
to sell and somebody to sell to.
That ain't never gonna change. Do you understand?
You can play all you want,
but if you don't have something to sell,
and if you don't have somebody to sell
to, you're dead in the water.
I don't care what anybody says. Yeah. So don't forget that.
So Co Sprout has been amazing on those two things.
It has been amazing on, on maintaining an audience.
Uh, it's been amazing on reengaging an old audience.
Tell me real quick, guys, what are your thoughts
when you come into this area and you see that there's points
and badges, rewards,
and you see all these comments happening over here
and all these goals over here and,
and the what are your thoughts?
What are your thoughts with this time? The chat.
Let me know. How did we do? Remember we built
that full stack in a month, little over a month, right?
Winston says exciting.
Craig says, you put in a lot of work, guys.
It's a topic for another call,
but most of the people that are coming through, uh,
if I were to open up another one, these are coming from ads.
Some of you, I think, uh, Winston,
somebody came in from an ad the other day, right?
People are coming in from ads.
When they come in here, they go through here,
they see the comments, they see the goals, they go,
oh my God, this is so much different.
This is so much better. This is real. This guy's on camera.
This is real. This is so much better
than the go high level stuff I was seeing, or this or that.
And, and so what do they do?
They come over here and they click these links
and they pay us more money,
and they keep paying us more money,
and then they join other things,
and then they hop on the workshops.
And do you guys understand this?
That's why we created this thing.
This should be your lifeline to take care of people,
to make more sales and to reengage old people.
Okay? I could do a whole entire training just on course,
prout, I probably will, but let's get through the open claw.
All right? So now we're gonna tell it
has it already trained the skill?
Let's go see. Did it say it trained the skill?
G Let's see, where's the result?
Found it. Uh, skill file. Updated.
Okay, so it's got the core sprout skill. Great.
Okay, so I'm gonna start today,
and then if I get stuck, I'll let G take over.
All right, so I'm gonna say, uh,
so we're gonna do a small test.
So I'm gonna come into the back
end, of course, sprout real quick.
And I'm gonna be fast guys.
I'm gonna come over here and I'm gonna create this, uh,
I'm gonna call this, uh, Pacino test.
Okay? Uh, this is a test
for the Pacino bot,
and I am the instructor.
Uh, it can do all this too, I think,
but right now I, what I wanna see it do is create
lessons inside of here.
Does that make sense to everybody? This is what we wanna do.
So if we open this up, okay, there's nothing here.
And what I wanna see it do is I want to see it, uh,
I'm even gonna get rid of this.
I wanna see it come over here and create these lessons
and start filling out the detail based on
what it is seen inside of a folder.
Okay? So now we're gonna come back over here to Vimeo
and let me see if I can do this.
Here's what we're gonna do,
uh, zoom recordings.
Okay? This is what I'm gonna do. Open cloud 4, 3, 2.
Uh, where is the first one?
Day two, hold on a second. Open cloud.
Shadow four, two.
Okay, let me, I think it's, uh, okay,
I'll, I'll cheat a little bit.
I'm just gonna give it a URL to start with. Okay?
So let's assist it a little bit. Here we go.
I want you to go find this video
in Vimeo and
grab the transcript.
We are going to take that transcript
and create a short lesson or short description
and a longer description for course Sprout.
Let's not place it in course Sprout route.
First, let's see what we come up with
for title.
Short description, and long description.
Make sense? Create a title Short.
Okay, everybody see what I'm doing here?
So let's see how it does. We already know it has a
Vimeo API key.
So all I wanted to do is go find
the transcript for this video.
Understand what is this video about?
Because if I have 10 videos there,
then I'm simply gonna say, here, go into this folder.
I created a folder called Open Claw Replay, open claw,
intensive, uh,
and let's build a course, right?
And I think that this thing will go into course Prout
and say, okay, what's the name of your course?
Um, I'm gonna call it open claw. Boom. Okay, perfect.
I created the course, I put the course description in.
I'm now going and grabbing the first video. Boom. Okay.
I created my lessons, I put my video URL there.
Do you want to include goal blocks? Chad? Yeah. Include.
Okay, I put the goal block going to get my second video.
Holy crap. I think that's where we're going guys,
how many of you're starting to see this right now?
That's insane, man.
You got a good window to jump on this stuff.
Is there anybody that's been out there
showcasing this stuff that you've been doing?
Because remember, I gave you a guide
that you can go out there and give away to
and start building up your brand.
You could start doing your own tutorials,
building out your own course route, right?
Alright, so let's see. Got it. Video is open claw day six.
Here's what I came up with.
Title, business automation
and multi API mastery at open claw.
Short description. Learn how
to build automated health checks for your business,
master efficient property strategies,
and watch real-time demonstrations
of open claw across multiple APIs simultaneously.
Boom, long description.
In this hands-on session, Chad reveals a mind shift, Seth,
that transforms Open cloud from a simple assistant
to a powerful business automation engine.
What you'll learn, how does that look?
Do you want me to tweak anything? Holy crap.
All right, I like it. You guys like it.
It's way better than what I did.
Let's take a look at what nicely did.
What in the world didn't nicely do? Hold on a minute, right?
I'm telling you guys, I need this for my own business.
What does our replay look like yesterday? I'm just curious.
How did we do yesterday with the descriptions?
Let's come over here. Shadow, replay number six.
What do we got in this session?
We're gonna give you an amazing command that allows you
to train API doc in full.
You're also gonna receive a command
that will take you from reactive to proactive.
We're also gonna continue our bridge page buildout. Alright?
I was half a asleep, half dead when I wrote that.
I think that this is so much better. Would you guys agree?
So let's ask it now.
The next thing I want to know is,
can it see this course?
So let's ask it. Let's ask it.
Can you see the Pacino test course?
Let's see what it says. If it does, I'm gonna be like, go.
Right. Let's see how it does.
Come on baby, don't let me down.
It is looking.
Yes. Pacino test course ID 3 49.
Go create a lesson with what you just came up with.
Here we go. Moment of truth.
What content did you want me to put the lesson?
I lost context. All right, that's fine, that's fine.
I was prepared for you.
Go create a lesson
in that thing.
Where did it find it? Oops, I jumped too far ahead.
Sorry guys. Go create a lesson in here.
Copy selected. Uh, what are all these check marks?
I don't know how telegram works. Hold on. Let's see.
Go create a lesson in, uh,
okay, see, I I couldn't even,
I I couldn't even paste it fast enough before it was done.
Done lesson created in Pacino.
Test title, business automation, short
and long description, all in there.
Type video ready for you, for you to link the actual video.
How to strip the emojis from the description.
API didn't like them. Want me
to try adding back a different way or is plain text fine?
Alright, let's go see what it did.
Remember guys, it's learning right now. Okay?
So if we go inside of here,
business automation, look at that.
Are you guys seeing this right now? Holy crap.
All right. Now what we have to do is,
let's see if we can get it to place the video.
URL in there, right?
Can you place the Vimeo
URL in the video library?
Alright, so that's something it needs to train on, right?
So let's see if it can do it.
I spelled that wrong, Rama. That's okay. Cancel.
Let me find the Vimeo. Okay, uh, here we go
with this freaking API, uh,
you got advice for me here on this?
We gotta figure out what's going on
with the Vimeo token, right?
G Let me grab this.
We were in six copy.
RL you there
GC paste
six.
All right. This is a first test.
I just wanna see if it can access everything it needs
to, to create the course.
Once we know it can do that, we're gonna say, okay,
remember what you just did?
And then the next step guys will be, Hey,
do you see this folder here?
Yes, there's three videos in there.
Can you go create the next three lessons done.
New lesson created with video heads up.
This created a second lesson since the API didn't have
access to the endpoint.
Now you have 6 0 1 3, no video, 6 0 1 4 with video.
Okay, let's go see what it's doing. It's learning here guys.
It's just like an employee.
It's gonna make mistakes, but we got this one here. Okay?
So here's the first lesson it created.
All right, no video. Here's the second lesson it created.
This one has a video. If we go look at it,
uh, I don't think it did that, right?
Okay, let's go back. The video.
URL has to be the full,
uh, Vimeo.
URL you.
Okay? So it's learning.
Are you guys getting a lot of value on this?
Pretty amazing, right? Got it.
Lesson id, video id, URL code. You now got three versions.
All right, that's okay. We're gonna
get it right here eventually.
All right, so let's come back over here.
Let's look at this again. Let's refresh it now.
Oh, I can see the video. URL there guys. It did it.
See the video came in here.
So let's make sure we got the name, the title,
the short description, the long description.
Let's come over here and see what it did for the Vimeo.
Right? There we go. So we got open cloth shadow day six.
It's missing the tag it put in the video URL.
All right, let's train it on the tag.
So come back over here.
Uh, for the tag, I need you
to come up with something that
represents the course.
In this instance, you could just
call it claw.
All the videos in this course would have that tag.
Does that make sense?
So now it's gonna tag all our videos guys.
Makes total sense. Video tags equals course identifier,
but chino test, open claw content is claw.
All lessons in that course share the same tag.
Keep the video library organized.
So next time I create a lesson, I'll include there.
Want me to create? Yes. Let's see if we got it.
How many of you're going? This is a little bit
easier than I thought it was gonna be.
Is anybody thinking that right now?
Man, we might have a slew of freaking launches, man.
How to create your course instantly with ai.
Dude, it's crazy man. I'm telling you right now, guys.
Opportunity is everything right now. You're timing on this.
Holy crap. Okay, done.
Lesson id, one thing the tag didn't apply
because it reused the video already in the library.
The API doesn't update tags on existing videos.
Clean, clean up. Pacino test 6, 0 1, 3 6 for the tags work,
you might need to add, uh, manually.
3, 3, 4, 5, all. Let's just go see what it did.
All right, refresh. Okay, so we got this guy
and we look at this and it still didn't add a tag.
Alright, so the reason why,
and it's okay, we could deal with this.
We're gonna try to do something different, okay?
The reason why it's having a trouble with this guys is
because it says this video's already in the library,
which it is because it's your replay.
Okay? Now, yes
or no, I want you to memorize
everything you just
did in the next test.
I'm going to give you access
to an entire Vimeo folder.
I'm gonna tell you to go build out
that course with those videos.
Make sense? All right, I wanna get, I want you
to memorize everything you just did in the next test.
I'm gonna give you access to an entire Vimeo folder.
I'm gonna tell you to go build
out that course with those videos.
Does it make sense? It says it loves it, I guess.
All right, so let's see what it does here.
Crystal clear, memorize workflow.
Get Vimeo folder with Vimeo.
For each video, create lesson via API, full Vimeo,
URL video, name for library video course
for course organization, title
and descriptions, no emojis,
all lessons land in target course videos
tagged and organized.
Ready for the folder? Let's build a course.
You guys ready for this? Who's ready for this?
Now let me think. Here's what I'm gonna do really fast.
I'm gonna come in here and I'm just going
to very quickly find something I know for a fact
is not in, uh,
yeah, okay, hold on a second.
Download. So I know
for a fact these are not in course routes.
Okay? So did that download, hold on a second,
I didn't even see it to dash.
Okay, yeah, that downloaded.
This one's gonna download, download
and this one's gonna download.
Download. Okay, perfect. So I got three new videos.
Lemme make sure that's gonna be our test.
Okay, here's our three videos.
Now I'm gonna come back over here
and I'm gonna create a brand new folder
because this is exactly
what we would do if we're gonna create a course.
I'm gonna call this Pacino bot confirm.
I can call it anything,
but I'm gonna go ahead and call that.
So now what I would do is I would go
and I would take my slides
or uh, I'd take Gamma or whatever.
I would go shoot those videos and I would just come in here
and I would start loading these videos.
And at the same time, uh, lemme see if I can find it.
There we go. At the same time, I would be telling Pacino,
Hey, I'm loading the videos for you.
Make sense? Is everybody getting this right now?
Now, right now
we're not gonna go into creating the course yet.
I don't know if we have the APIs to do that.
I think we do, but I don't know for sure.
So I'm just gonna go ahead and tell it to, uh,
keep building out this here.
Alright, so let's try this.
So Pacino bot is the name of my folder. So here we go.
I have a folder called Pacino
Bot on Vimeo.
And I want you to, uh, start
building out the courses in
Pacino test in course route.
Good. All right, here we go. Moment of truth.
Moment of truth. So it's gonna go into Vimeo. Love it.
I hit a wall earlier. The Vimeo token expired.
When I tried searching for the videos,
we will figure out what to do.
Gee, are you there? 'cause I need you to respond.
We'll figure out what to do with this Vimeo thing.
That's their API.
Uh, but right now, here's what I'm gonna do.
I'm just going to cheat a little bit
and I'm gonna tell it where to find that, okay?
Because I, that's not a, that's not a deal breaker,
Renee, maybe you can help me with that.
All right, let's see if we can find the
folder on a second.
Let's see if the guys are around. All right.
The Uur l shows page not found looks incomplete
with folder, but no folder.
Give me the full folder. Okay, hold on a second.
That damn URLs that API is screwing us up.
That's their API though that's not ours. Let's see.
Come on now.
Pne, can you hear me? Yeah.
This Vimeo API is screwing us up
because the token keeps expiring.
Can you figure out what's up with that?
Yeah, I'll check
Vimeo user.
All right, come on baby. I know it's gonna do it guys.
I, how many of you believe it's already gonna do it?
I think it's gonna go in there.
It's gonna grab those three videos.
It's gonna create three lessons.
Now, does it know what order to put 'em in?
No, but I could probably do, uh,
I could probably put a one in front of the video,
a two in front of the video, a three in video
and say, look, I've already put 'em in
the order that you need.
I could do it every single time I create a course, okay?
And I'm pretty sure that it can just go do
all three videos at once.
Now, is there anybody surprised at how direct I am with it?
Very, very short. What is the MVP
necessary to get the result?
That's it. That's it, right?
But you also see that we're doing baby steps here.
The first thing was we wanted to see, hey,
could it actually go create the, could it, could it,
could it create the copy like we wanted?
Yes it did. Okay.
Next thing was could it,
could it access the lesson area in the title area?
Yes, it could. Alright, next,
could you put the video in there?
Yes, but you missed this whole tag thing.
All right, so we went back and forth on that.
Boom, it got all that perfect.
Alright, now let's see if you can do multiple videos at
once, right?
Yeah, G is nicer, he's totally nicer. Super, super nice.
That's not me. I just want results. Right? Here we go.
Found the Pacino bot folder. It has three videos.
Let me gather video URLs so I can build the lessons.
I got the first one, boom. Got the second one, boom.
Got all three. Now I'm creating all three lessons in the
Pacino test with tag done.
All three lessons created in Pacino test.
Say what? Seriously, all tagged
with Pacino in the video library?
You got four duplicate lessons from our earlier tests.
I'm pretty sure I deleted those, didn't I?
Maybe I didn't, but let's see if we refresh.
Let's come on over here. Look at that guys.
I'm telling you, I'm telling you.
Are you guys seeing this right now?
Now look, I'm gonna delete it.
I'm gonna tell it to do, to follow the copy that we did
before, but it clearly
is looking at these videos.
It didn't have this anywhere.
So it is transcribing those videos and it is creating that.
Did everybody see it? Create this course.
That's it. All it did was go to Vimeo, grab those videos
and came over here and created the course.
Now watch, I'm gonna, we're gonna delete this here.
Let's delete this for a minute. Okay, let's try this again.
I think you need to do better on those descriptions.
You think, all right, let's try it again.
Let's run it again. Here we go.
We're gonna run this course again.
Let's see if we can do better on the descriptions.
If it can. I'm gonna say, okay, always do it that way.
Memorize that and don't deviate from it. Okay?
So let's see if we're typing over here.
By the way, you guys liking this?
Is this not amazing or what we gave you the API
to be able to do this.
We gave this to you. All right? Yeah, those were lazy.
Let me pull the transcripts from each video
and write proper descriptions like I did for day six.
So maybe, ah, see,
maybe it didn't actually pull the transcripts.
It probably just looked at the title of video and winged it.
We're not gonna do that. We're not gonna
let it do that, right?
I can't pull the transcripts videos,
were just uploaded today.
No auto captions yet. Two options.
Tell me what video covers
and I'll write proper descriptions.
I can watch each one via the browser and take notes.
What do you prefer? Alright,
we're not gonna watch it during the browser.
Uh, here's what I'm gonna do.
Alright, so we just learned something.
So that means for Vimeo anyways, it takes a little bit
for the transcripts to appear, okay?
So, uh, it's still trying to get that token
videos are set to hide.
Okay? Hold on a minute. That's probably a problem.
So I'm gonna come over here, see this right here with Vimeo.
It has this sting over here where it's hidden
that might have been stopping it from accessing.
So let me come over here and reset the permissions so
that it can read it and then we're gonna try again.
And guys, you're gonna be up against this on all software.
Okay? So let's try this again.
Two and yep,
it's telling me I can read it on the phone
that the Vimeo are, the videos are hidden from me.
Okay? So,
and that's a default setting that we have,
um, inside of Vimeo.
Try it again. They are public.
Alright, let's see if we can do it now.
Anything on that, that token pne?
Uh, no, not yet.
You might ask perplexed or GPT what to do with that.
Okay, Try it again. They're public. Okay, let's see.
Remember guys, we're gonna get to the goal block too
now with this one G, are you there?
Yeah,
I'm here.
This might be one that we can figure out how to give them
as an MD file or something so
that when they bring it over course route is just
trained. Do you think we could do that?
Yeah, we can do that. Yeah.
'cause I am spending a little bit
of time training this thing.
'cause I know the software well got two or three.
The dashboard video is still returning 4 0 4.
Let me write proper description for those while you check.
All right. So it's fine. That's good. All right.
So it's telling me, I'm sorry, daddy.
I did better this time. Can I continue?
Uh, want me to create lessons?
Uh, okay, so let's figure out
what's going on with the dashboard.
One dashboard.
See Dashboard. Oh, he's right.
It was set to, all right, let's try it again.
All right, go get the dashboard.
Do me a favor, G, bring Keith
and Hannah on the call, please.
Can you do that? Yeah,
Can. And
Another guy, I want them to see this stuff.
Right now I got another team of VAs guys
that is building courses
by hand in our other company as we speak.
This very moment. They are going in there,
they're clicking a button that says Create lesson.
They are running the title through chat, GBT.
They're doing all this manually.
They've been doing it for four days. Now.
Four days of work can be done, I think in about an hour
for all those courses, right?
All right, so, uh, go get dashboard.
You're thinking, what the heck does that mean?
Well, it knows what it means. So let's see.
It's gonna get all three videos.
All three videos. Do you see Nick Co on a call right now, G
No, he's not here.
Yeah, but is he on a Zoom call in the other meeting?
Or let me invite him. No, he's not. I'm gonna invite him.
Okay. Got it.
Now, creating all three lessons with proper descriptions,
look at this here guys.
Dashboard tour, full walkthrough,
understanding your statistics, rewards, tour library,
all tagged with Pacino
and linked to the correct Vimeo URLs.
Okay, let's come over here and let's see what it did.
Let's see what it did. There we go. Three videos.
Let's go look at it all. It's getting a little bit better.
We gotta work on the format a little bit,
but at least it's pulling in the right text.
So you guys seeing this? We have a nice long
description, okay?
And if we click here, we have the video, boom,
we have the tag, we have the video, URL, okay?
And over here, let's look at this again. Okay?
And let's look at our third one and let's open this up.
Boom, we got it.
All right, I'm gonna do one final test ready for this.
I'm gonna come over here and I wanted
to do it all over again, just once without any delays
from Vimeo or anything else.
I delete the lessons. I want you to do it
one more time now that everything
is set to public.
Here we go. Ready? Moment of truth. Let's see what happens.
Let's see what happens.
I'm telling you guys' game changing stuff. Here we go.
You ready for this? We're gonna do it one more time, right?
The course is completely empty right now.
All there is is one Vimeo folder
with three videos that we've thrown in there.
That's it. That's all we have.
If we come back over here
and it should go grab those videos, transcribe those videos,
create a short lesson, create a loan description,
place the video in the library
with the tags and everything else.
And that means that we could essentially go shoot 50
different videos, drop 'em in a video folder
or anything else, and it should go build our course.
Let's do it. Alright, full workflow,
complete transcripts, poll, boom.
Three videos, lessons created inside of Pacino test,
all tagged with Pacino,
with full descriptions for the transcripts.
Alright, let's go back into Core Sprout. Nothing is here.
Let's refresh it.
Let's open it up and then boom, there's our three lessons.
Let's look at it. We got a title,
short description, long description.
We gotta format this bad boy a little bit.
Same thing for lesson number two. There we go.
And now we have the same thing for lesson three. Guys.
We're living in the Jetsons.
Are you guys seeing this type of the chat here?
Who is seeing this in real time?
Now, I'm gonna come back over here
and I am gonna say, perfect.
Freaking memorize that, memorize
that, memorize that.
And there we go. Look at that. Look at the comments, guys.
Look at this. Everybody is blown away by this.
Are you guys seeing this? Is this not crazy? Or what?
And every single one of you now have the ability
to go out there and crack your own code, come up
with your own strategies, start shooting your little videos
if you want to, and throw on 'em in a folder.
And this thing could turn around
and build the same type of courses that we're building
all automatically with open claw memorize workflow,
locked in video folder, extract video URLs,
pull the transcripts, generate real
descriptions, create the lessons.
Point me at any video meal folder in
course, and I'll build it out.
Any questions?
That is crazy. That is crazy.
Hold on a second. Nick.
Co. What's up dog?
Hey, how's it going, Chad? That's,
that's pretty exciting stuff.
Um, I was, uh, really, really, uh,
in intrigued about how this could work.
If you have, um, a really massive course.
You know, like some of our courses are like eight hours,
some of it we have archives of like dozens of hours
and they're organized by date.
Does this also allow you to organize it chronologically?
Ah, that's great. That's amazing.
Um, I guess, uh, yeah, I mean, the amount
of time this could save is, is pretty impressive.
Super excited by by that.
And I guess we're gonna be
doing that for our company as well.
Right now, I'm pretty sure Hannah's here.
I'm pretty sure Keith is here.
They're doing all this stuff manually right now.
Okay, well I know
that we hired us multiple people like Danny
and other people to kinda like manually type in each
of the descriptions and everything.
And the fact that this could put that in
and save a lot of time is pretty cool.
Yeah. So not that we wanna let them go.
What we want them to do is be the ones running the ai.
I heard a really good expression the other day that I love,
and everybody for the past years have been saying
that AI's gonna replace your job.
No, the person
that's gonna replace you is the person running the ai.
Yeah, that's gonna be, well, I also think that the, uh,
refinement of of, of also some of the language
and the verbiage and like really understanding the
customer's needs can also be added to this.
So I guess kind of gives you like a quick run through,
put something together that the customers could use.
And then we could kind of just add a little bit more if
like, maybe every now
and then we could add like a do sales copy or bonus.
'cause this course could also be something
that could upsell everything else a lot easier.
Now we have all this time,
but from this course auto created,
we could now focus on auto little things to add marketing
and upsells into things too.
This is just one thing that I brought you on today.
This thing's writing and sending out emails.
This thing is creating freaking pages, taking our replays,
transcribing our videos.
Uh, it it sends me an update every day telling
me my software's good.
It checks all. You have very, very important links
that you wanna make sure are online all the time.
It could check those links every single
day, make sure they're good.
It looks at our ad stats.
It could give you a report of your sales.
It could tell you how many leads you brought in Nick, right?
Uh, it could tell you how many employees showed up today.
It, it can give you insights of everything.
It can replace everything
that all the staff members are doing, uh, in your business.
Uh, today I'm gonna give 'em a prompt
that's gonna create a second brain inside
of their open claw.
So it can take any ideas that you have.
'cause I know you have ideas all the time.
You have books everywhere. You can just say,
Hey, put that in my second brain.
And it can go and start exploring that idea on its own
and come back and give you analysis and some ideas
and get, actually start, get you building on it.
Um, it it,
and what happens is this thing first learns to be,
this is how it works, Nick.
It first learns to be a va.
It starts learning your daily day task.
It starts creating skills.
Obviously our software, we're starting with us
'cause we understand APIs.
It's trained completely on all, almost all
of our software like you just saw.
Okay? Um,
and then what happens is when it starts learning those
things, it starts going from reactive to proactive.
So you might start teaching it stuff,
but then pretty soon you start changing your language.
You start saying, Hey, what I
what ideas do you have for this?
What do you think we can do for this?
And then it starts giving you ideas
and then without you even asking,
it starts suggesting things to optimize your business
to become more efficient, to become more lean and mean.
And then what happens is it can maintain the role
of all the VAs.
Now it becomes your CEO.
Yeah. Well, this sounds great.
I I would love to do this also with the,
the bonuses we're bringing in a lot of new influencers.
Uh, I do, we have like 10 of them, 10 new ones, and,
and all of 'em are gonna have their own courses.
All of 'em are gonna have their own webinars.
And even the videos, we're having them record for the,
the intro bonuses that lead to upsells and other webinars.
This could be a great way to also just
add all that content for them too.
Yeah. So you, you as like, I, I, I see you as a client,
but you speak on stages all around the world with ai.
If you could have done the demo I just did in the time,
I just did tell me
that whole stadium would not have flipped out.
You spoke on the biggest stages at Utah for Adobe.
You spoke at some pretty big events, right?
You were the keynote speaker. If you had done the That's
right demo that I just did just now, what would
that response have been with that crowd?
Yeah, I mean, especially for, in most of our,
our companies that I've been working
with are not creating just educational projects.
They're actually creating entire, like, HR processes,
training materials, and they have tons
of videos for, for that stuff.
We're not talking about like five, three videos.
We're talking about like five or 3000 videos.
And so the fact that they could have this kind of updated
or added would be a great bonus.
And I remember I was doing a, a presentation for a,
a program that was just about building a, a good HR process
and how AI could accelerate
and save so much time for people.
And, and I think the biggest concern that HR people had
was being completely replaced.
But there's a lot of manual things that they just don't want
to do that just are never getting done.
And it just makes them look better if it's a feather their
cap to be able to have all this information organized better
and they can do their job faster.
Um, I think that, you know,
something like this could definitely help
for those large current organizations
that are outside of education.
But for education people, like, I think many
of the people in this car having newsletters
or educational courses
and publishing, I think that
also would be a great way to do that.
I, I think that right now we're migrating something
somewhere, several, several dozen if not a hundred courses,
like from our old platform Kajabi onto Course Sprout,
because we really like all these features.
So this is the kind of thing
that could also save a lot of time. We manually,
We did it all manually.
It took us months. We could have done it
in a single day this way.
Isn't it crazy?
Yeah. Well that, that's good
because it allows us to bring more influencers
onto the platform faster.
So it's really, especially since, you know, that's
before having a team of influencers
that we're bringing onto the platform.
Now we can bring on 10
or I mean, if we did a, one of the things
that we've been talking about is launching the, the next,
uh, influencer kind of program,
kinda like an American Idol program to bring influencers on.
And this could be a way that they could also have all their
content on there, interact, showcase their stuff.
People who complete a certification program could then have
their stuff on this platform
and that could bring in a lot of leads and sales.
And having something that could add this kind of value
to save this much time would definitely be a good value add,
um, to the people that are brought onto our platform since,
especially since they're giving us half
of their overall revenue.
Well, this is what we're doing in this workshop every day.
I just thought about just calling you in.
I'm glad you showed, but if you could,
when you can attend these things, I wanna come back to you
because, uh, you are really, really good at going out there
and just selling AI services better than anybody I know.
So I think you guys would really, really value his input
with what he's seeing here and what can be positioned
and what could be sold out there.
Because I'm gonna tell you guys right now, Nick,
I think we're the only ones on the planet that are doing
what you're actually seeing here on the screen.
I have not seen anybody else, Ty in APIs in there
and actually making it do this stuff.
What we've seen is that if you look on YouTube
or whatever, people are letting it have access
to their Google Drive and it's renaming folders
and, and stuff like that.
Nobody's using it for software like we are right now.
So I'm trying to tell these guys
that we brought you this opportunity right at the perfect
time, right?
So I want to check back in with you,
but there's something else I want to do,
and she's gonna kill me for doing this.
Uh, I love her to death,
but I want to put, uh, uh, one of my VA managers,
uh, on the call right now.
She's actually assisting, uh, Nick with his company,
but I, I wanna get her perspective on this too real quick.
Hannah, are you there? Can you talk to me for a minute?
Hey, Chad. Hey everybody.
Can you guys say hi to Hannah?
So Hannah is, uh, based in the Philippines.
Uh, she's been with me for a very long time.
Uh, she is absolutely amazing.
You guys have all, uh, dealt with her a lot through support.
She oversees the support team.
She can pretty much do everything in my business, right?
She's one that I will keep no matter what happens to ai.
Um, but Hannah, what's your take on what you just saw
and what does it mean for VAs?
What does it mean for, uh, people in the Philippines now
that you're seeing the technology of what AI can do?
Honestly, uh, um, I'm afraid for them,
this will literally replace VAs, honestly.
Chad,
Do you think there's an oppor?
Do you think it's, do you think it's in your best
interest to learn?
First of all, you're safe with me.
I'm saying if you weren't safe with me,
do you think it's in your best interest as a VA
or a VA manager to learn how to control all these tools?
Yeah. So that you become your client before they come to you
and say, Hey, I have figured out this incredible process
that is gonna do this, this, this, this, this, this, this,
and we can get it all set up.
And now you become like that, that manager of the, uh,
AI platforms, right?
Yes. Mm-hmm. That is correct, Chad.
I think that this will give me more opportunity
to learn more stuff, do more tasks,
and, um, things will be much more easier for us,
especially everything
that we've been doing it manually at this time.
And, um, you know, multiple tasks at the same time.
This is really helpful.
I'm so amazed with what I saw, especially with the courses,
knowing that we've been uploading it manually at the moment.
So this is crazy.
So, um, like I said, it's not something you have
to worry about, but what you,
you are gonna be doing is you're gonna,
guys, what's gonna happen?
I'm sure you see this, Nick.
This is what blows my mind, okay?
Uh, since we turn on all our APIs, when this thing,
we use Zoom Messenger as our communication channel,
when this thing drops messages into Zoom Messenger
and my whole team is in there, Hannah's gonna be like, uh,
hey Pacino, can you go reset the password
for Nick on course Sprout?
Boom, done. I already mailed him access, right?
Or she's gonna be like, Hey, Pacino,
I just put all the videos
that Chad shot in this course, or whatever.
Can you go build that course? Boom, it's done.
Do you see like, she's going to be like the one, um, um,
overseeing the ai.
Now, does that make sense?
So we get to set it up on CR jobs.
So for instance, and I've told you guys this,
I got the local newsletter call at 10 o'clock.
We go about an hour and a half.
That means that about two o'clock,
because my, uh,
zoom automatically goes in a Vimeo at two o'clock.
Pacino, my open claw should go into Zoom via the API grab
that replay, go into member, create that page,
create the replay, write the email, send it all out.
It gets to do all that on its own, guys, okay?
The Quran jobs, it can do on its own.
But what about the stuff that just comes up like that, that,
that is not on a schedule?
Well, that's where you have your open claw trained,
and then somebody like Hannah's like, okay,
Chad, put those videos there.
Go to work. Does that make sense?
She becomes the supervisor for the ai.
The AI still needs a a boss.
It's gonna be able to do things
and it's gonna report what it's doing to you.
But in my opinion, it still needs a human boss
because it also has a mind of its own.
And it'll report when it's been naughty.
I sent out three emails this weekend
to 366 of the same people.
I'm like, you are a bonehead. Why did you do that? Right?
So it still needs something there to oversee
and make sure it's doing things,
especially in the infant stages.
Okay? Is that giving you guys some better ideas?
Thanks for hopping on, Nick. Stick around, man.
Appreciate it. We gotta
implement this stuff for your business.
Yeah, sounds good. Exciting all the
other businesses we're working with.
Yeah. Cool. Uh, okay, does everybody get this?
Now you've heard two different perspectives.
You've heard from somebody that's, uh,
international speaker all
around the world selling on AI stages.
How big of an opportunity is there?
You also heard from somebody, uh,
that's been in the VA business in the Philippines.
You heard it directly from her. And what'd she say?
I'm scared. Yeah. Yeah. So opportunity's everything.
There's no reason for anybody on this call
to be scared, guys.
It is opportunity.
It's opportunity for me, opportunity for Nick,
opportunity for all of you.
It's opportunity for Hannah and Keith because of the timing.
Unfortunately, for a lot of other people,
they're gonna be late on this thing, but not you guys.
Okay? So let's continue the demo.
Now, here's what I want to know.
So I'm gonna come over here
because I don't know its capabilities, but let's do this.
I'm gonna share my screen again.
Let's see if it can actually create
the course and everything.
And then we'll go into the goal blocks.
Uh, if there wasn't
a course there, can you guys see my screen?
Could you create it for me? All right.
Let's see what it can do. I don't know if
that API endpoint was done.
I'm so focused on creating the lessons with the videos
and everything, but let's see if it can do that.
Yes, the API has the ability to create the course, create
a new course called, uh,
Robert De Niro.
All right. Let's see. I'm a big Pacino fan.
That's a joke, guys. All right. Let's see.
It creates first chapter, first lessons.
Let's see if we can do this.
And while it's doing that, let's come over here
and see if we could find what it's doing.
Done created the course. Let's come over here. Let's see.
Booya. It created the course. It created the course, guys.
All right, so let's go ahead and see. Uh, let's see.
ID three 50 Slug Robert De Niro, chapter one. All right.
Um, uh, this, I'm gonna say this, this course is going
to be about, uh, okay, let's do this one.
Create another course called Open Claw
for Dummies.
All right? Include the description.
Find a way to create an image for it.
Actually create the logos too, if you can.
All right, let's see what it can do.
Who knows what it can do, man? Let's just go see, right?
So it already created this one for Robert De Niro.
Let's go see if it can create another one
for open Claw for Dummies.
Are you guys seeing this right now? Are you seeing this?
And the next step is, so the only work becomes the lessons.
Well, this thing can go lay out your lessons for you too.
Now it's up to you. If you just want to go tie in, Hey, Jen
and 11 Labs and, and create those, those lessons.
I know right now PowerPoint plus, Claude, uh, not Claude,
but um, uh, grok 4.6, whatever it is,
is doing amazing stuff, right?
So course created, uh, description, no nonsense guide
to turning open claw into your personal
AI power business assistant.
No coding required, no tech degree.
Now for the image logo, I don't have a direct image
generation AI options browser.
Uh, uh, let's see. Image gen, uh, let's see.
Chad, GPTI think we did give it, I think I did
give you the API key.
Are you there, G?
Yeah, I'm here. It does have an API key
to do it with Dolly, doesn't it?
Uh, to create an image.
Yeah, I think it uses image generation
with open AI right now.
You gotta enable this skill though.
I'll tell you right now, guys,
open AI is doing amazing logos.
So you can see up here at the top it is typing.
Uh, guys, I am bound to determine, to show you
in this call, it's gonna start with nothing.
It's gonna have one Vimeo folder.
It is gonna go create the course, create the logo,
create the image, create the description for the course,
open up the course, create the lessons.
We already saw it. Create the loan description,
create the short description, place the video,
and we're gonna get to the goal block too.
How many of you think we can get that done?
And then it's gonna be trained.
And then I'm gonna give you guys that skill.
Is there anybody that needs that skill?
Anybody that needs that skill?
Matt, can you see this being a launch?
Just the course part.
Let's see.
Alright, what do we got?
Uh, okay, done. Core Sprout.
Open Claw for dummies, cover image, robot handling,
hand handholding, uh, for dummies book,
classic yellow block style, clean badge design
with Circuit Claw icon for beginner style,
both saved to workspace.
Okay, you want me, uh, I want you
to place them in course route.
Now what we need to do is we need
to give it some image sizes to get it perfectly,
but I don't care right now.
I just wanna see if it can go
and create a course with these images here.
Uh, do you know what the pne, can you look up the size
that we need to have for the image, the logo, the fave icon?
Can you find all that out for me? Yeah. Okay.
Quick clarification. Uh, let's see the logo.
We just saved videos from a Vimeo,
a new course called Open Claw for Dummies.
I've got the course Proud. API Ready. Just know.
Okay, here's what I'm gonna do again.
Uh, let's see. It's a little bit confused.
Let me see what it's done first. So it created this course.
Okay, so it's come down here, it created this course.
Open Claw for Dummies.
Okay, so, uh,
what I want it to do, and you know what though?
Course image course logo, tab icon.
I want it to fill in these details here
and then Mattel it to choose the main color.
Let's see. Do you have the
API endpoint to load
the course image course logo
fave icon?
It might not have that. And if it doesn't, it's okay.
We'll go update the endpoints
and then we'll give it another round.
Okay? So let's see.
Current co release steps, title, description,
main color, no input.
Okay, fine. So we'll get these end points added. All right?
That's the reason why it struggled, okay?
But it did go create this. So here's what I'm gonna do.
I'm gonna come back over here. I'm going to delete this.
I'm gonna come back over here, this folder,
and we're gonna do a, a test from the very beginning.
Okay? All right, so watch this.
You ready for this? Guys? Here we go.
This is the, this is the moment of truth.
You ready for this? I'm gonna open up Telegram.
I'm at freaking In and Out Burger, having my double double.
You ready? All right.
Hey, Pacino, I just shot a bunch of videos,
uh, for the new course.
It's gonna be called Open Claw for Dummies.
Uh, the Vimeo folder is called Pacino Bot.
Uh, can you go ahead and start building out that course?
You guys saw that? Yeah, I sent that audio message
through Telegram, and it wasn't a very good one.
It was a half ass message.
But let's come back over here
and let's see what we're doing, right?
Screen one, there's the audio message.
You can see it is typing up here. Okay?
You're seeing this right now, right Nick?
All right, typing
it might ask for something that was not a very good, uh,
that was not a very good direction.
And I did that on purpose 'cause I wanted to see
what it could figure out based on what we trained it on.
And let me just make sure I deleted that course.
Let's come back over here.
Let's reload this all, all right, here we go.
Here we go guys. Look at this. Look at this on it.
Let me journal this course created.
Let me get the course Id, let me fetch a fresh Vimeo token.
Boom. The Vimeo, API
with client credentials can access your private folders.
I need the video URLs directly.
Alright, so that API is a pain in the ass
and it's screwing up my demo,
but I'll grab the transcripts, build out lessons,
I have them, of course, open Claw
for Dummies is ready and waiting.
Hold on a minute. Come on, y'all reload.
Let's come over here. Open Claw for Dummies.
Let's go ahead and open that up.
Open Claw for Dummies, your complete guy for getting started
with Open AI claw assistant.
It didn't choose an instructor, but we could tell
with that main color.
We'll get the images in there. But now let's come over here.
Let's look at the lesson. Okay, now let's go ahead
and we're getting close.
We're getting close. So this Vimeo thing,
uh, pne, are you there?
Yes. What can we do with this? API,
Uh, I think it's trying to log in using your credential.
Yeah, but the API keeps expiring or something.
Um, Chad, so for that one, it always uses o
and the problem with O is it's not
integrated to our system, right?
So it keeps trying to use the oath,
and that's how the token expires.
Okay? So we can integrate it with our system.
Um, we can try, but yeah, I gotta explore that first.
Okay? Let's, let's explore that pne. Okay? Yeah.
So in the meantime, in the meantime, man,
that's a pain in the ass because I wanna
show how to do this from the phone.
In the meantime, I'm gonna go ahead
and give it this folder, okay?
Vimeo's API is screwy, guys, it's not us.
That's, it's, it's not open claw.
It's, it's Vimeo's API, it's just screwy, right?
So, uh, I'm gonna start working on the goal blocks.
I am convinced, I am convinced it can do this guys.
Are you guys convinced who's convinced on this call
I might have to build, I might have to switch to Vimeo?
No, no, no, no, no.
What you need to do is find out what you're using
to host your Vimeo or your videos, right?
So I I, you guys can tell me the name of those things,
just go find out if they have an API
just go find out if they have an API.
This Vimeo, API is kind of a pain in the ass actually,
because it's using OAuth, right?
API can't access that folder even when private is false.
So it did access the folder though.
It did access the folder.
So I'm a little frustrated with, uh, Vimeo.
But while you guys, uh, gee,
can you see if you can do something to help me
with the Vimeo to get a perfect demo today?
Okay? Yeah. Uh, I'll be talking with, uh,
that bot through VPS.
So I don't want you to do anything
with Telegram. Is that fine?
No. 'cause I'm gonna try to teach it on a goal block.
Can you get into one of our other ones?
Okay. Alright, so let's work on the goal block, guys.
Okay, so let's work on the goal block. All right?
So, um, let's come over here real quick.
Here's what I'm gonna ask it. Okay?
Actually, let me find one that's really, really good.
Let's train on what a goal block looks like.
Okay, so if I come over here to local Newsletter Hustle,
and, and by the way, we're doing all this manually too.
Okay? 2,369 comments. Let's go open this up.
You guys have all seen this before.
Uh, these goals are amazing. Yeah.
So I'm gonna come over here and see
goal what to reflect on Goal summary.
I'm gonna get a little bit more technical. Hold on a second.
Let me, that's not a very good goal block.
Uh, a bad goal block is better than none.
Uh, let's come over here. Let's look at this one.
Okay, this one's got a lot of activity. 51 goals.
Let's see what this is. Goal answer these questions.
Complete the goal block. Okay, so I'm gonna give it this
and let's see what it can do.
Can you access the goal block on, uh,
this course lesson?
All right, let's see what we got.
Can you access a goal block on this course lesson?
Uh, so far it's not typing.
Uh, what happened? Are you there? Did something happen, g
Um, it's, it's, it's turning through the BMU.
I think, uh, give it a minute. It'll reply
Because it's usually typing up there.
Okay? So let me tell you what the goal is, guys.
And this one's challenging. It's very important, right?
The reason why our stuff is magical.
The reason why you love it when you come in here is one
reason and one reason only.
It is these goal blocks.
These goal blocks are what build up the social proof.
They build up the trophies,
they give us our leaderboard over here.
They have the comments coming in with the points,
the badges, the rewards.
Like everything is based off the goal blocks.
Now, I think guys, probably not today,
but I think you here in the very near future, as opposed
to just beating out in and out burgers
and saying, Hey, I did the videos for you.
I actually think that we can say, okay,
I wanna create a new course today.
All right? And with that, you're gonna say,
and I want to go full-blown.
I wanna have points, badges, rewards.
It's gonna be about 25 lessons.
Uh, and so let's create this thing for reels.
And so it's gonna go and it's gonna create the logo for you.
It's gonna create all the badges for you.
Uh, it's gonna take your videos, it's going
to create the course, create the course description,
create all the lessons, uh, the short description,
law description, place all the videos.
And then I truly believe that it's gonna go in here
and it's gonna create all of your courses for you as well.
And all your goal blocks, everything.
It's gonna create everything, guys.
All the magic that you see that I've always done
because I put a little bit of extra work in it
that other people aren't willing to do.
I think that you can have exactly
what you're seeing here on the screen.
Now, yes or no, how many of you would love to be able to do
that with course sprouts?
How, how many of you would love to be able to do
what you're seeing here on the screen?
Yes or no? There's no secret to it.
The only secret is I just put more work into it
than most people are willing to.
I make sure that I go through
and I put, uh, multiple goals.
I put goals on everything.
And so you can't, you can't move outta the lesson
until you complete the goal.
That's the magic we created
that 14 years ago with Lev ever lesson.
We, uh, cloned it over here with Course Sprout
and I've just continued it, right?
So let's see what it says. So let's see what it says.
Okay, so, uh, here, let me check
that the lessons got goal block API doesn't have an endpoint
to read the goal blocks from existing lessons
only to create new goals.
Okay? Fair enough. So here's what I'm gonna do.
If I'm thinking that I like this goal block, okay, this is
where I'm gonna start.
And I told you guys this yesterday.
I'm gonna come over here and I'm gonna go ahead
and zoom outta this bad boy, okay?
And that's a pretty long goal block.
Uh, but let me zoom out one more time.
I am not gonna waste my tokens going back
and forth with open claw.
Okay? So what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna grab a screenshot
of the very best, ideal situation, save as
save
Ashley, hold on a second.
So it can't access, yeah, that sucks.
I'm learning something right now.
I would rather just go create it for this
and say I've already given you the structure as opposed
to, right?
We're gonna try something different. File save as.
This is a good lesson for you guys. Anyways, so
to save this, right, we're gonna say this in a seven, okay?
And let's come over here.
I'm in perplexity right now, but I'll do chat.
GBT, that's what you guys are used to.
And I'll go ahead and say add photos. Okay?
So I don't wanna start with open claw, okay?
So, uh, let me come over here. Let me grab that.
Here is the goal block
Structure that we use
for course route lessons.
I need open claw to create the same thing.
Uh, once it has transcribed
the video, can you help me create
the command that's going to teach it?
All right, so here we go. Let's see what we got.
By the way, type in the chat here. A scale of one out of 10.
How much value you guys getting on the call? Is it good?
Is it good? Alright,
open clock command course Sprout block generator roll.
You are a course sprout lesson goal, block creator input.
You'll receive less entitled transcript optional, uh,
primary offer name, okay, uh, your job.
Convert the transcript into course style.
Uh, that matches this exact structure.
Okay, hold on a minute. I forgot to tell you.
It already has the transcript.
It's already created the lessons. Okay?
Uh, it just needs to do the goal block.
All right, here we go. Here we go. Here we go. Here we go.
Let's do this thing. Perfect.
That actually makes this much cleaner.
It has a transcript, it has a lesson created.
Just needs to create the goal block. Open clock command.
You are a course route. Lesson blocker
generated a lesson already exists.
The transcript has already been processed.
Your only job is to generate the goal Block content.
Do not rewrite the lesson. Do not summarize the full video.
Do not add extra commentary.
Use a lesson content transcript, uh,
to generate a structured goal block in the exact course
route format required output structure.
You must output exactly the structure. Nothing else.
Summary. Follow these steps. Goal summary.
Uh, once you're specific out from this lesson, live,
drop a message below.
Okay? So that is
great for the format.
However, let's talk about the quality
we need for it to create
the very best goals
that are consistent
and congruent with what's being
taught, being shown, shown,
uh, taught in the video, okay?
I usually create a goal block
where the user can, uh, do some kind
of action or,
uh, follow specific instructions,
especially, uh, if it's software
related, uh,
or about a specific, uh, strategy.
Or if we don't have an action,
I might ask them how well they understand
the concepts, how excited they are,
I might, uh, future pace, uh,
what their future could look like.
I'm giving you guys the secret right now, by the way, right?
Uh, how excited they are on a scale
of one outta 10.
Uh, what their big light bulb,
uh, moment is, what
their, uh, epiphany is.
Makes sense. All right. So it focused on the structure.
It focused on the structure.
But now what we need to do is we need
to focus on the quality
doesn't makes perfect sense right now.
We solve the structure right now.
We need to solve intelligence plus alignment plus intention.
You don't just wanna format a block.
You want goals that match the actual lesson. Clear action.
When action exists. Deep reflection when it's conceptual.
Consistent tone across all lessons.
No generic fluff, no made up steps, no AI sounding garbage.
So the fix is just format rules. We need to teach open claw.
How to think before it writes.
You guys see the value of Chad Patino,
the real upgrade adolescent type decision engine
before it generates a block, it must classify the lesson.
Add this logic layer inside the command.
Step one, classify the lesson type,
analyze the lesson content, determine which
of the following type it is.
Type A, tactical software, execution.
The lesson shows buttons being clicked,
pages being navigated, set up being done,
a workflow being built, a campaign being launched,
a configuration being adjusted if this is detected.
Goal block must be actionable steps. Type B, strategic.
The lesson teaches a system, a position, idea,
funnel strategy, a monetization method, a model explanation,
a concept of how this works.
If this is detected, the goal block must include a thinking
exercise, a planning prompt, a future pacing, prompt a map,
uh, to this business action type C mindset or conceptual.
Most of the stuff in Nick's company is this, right?
The lesson is awareness based.
Phil, philosophical, vision driven, energy based,
pattern recognition,
big picture explanation if this is detected.
The goal block must include self-evaluation, light bulb,
epiphany, prompt, future pacing,
emotional engagement questions.
Type D hybrid most common, uh, contains some execution.
Strategy mindset. If hybrid include three
to five action steps plus two reflection prompts at the end.
Step two, alignment roles Before writing the goal block.
Extract the core promise of the lesson.
What transformation happened in the video?
Extract the actual outcome.
Demonstrated what change on the screen.
Extract any specific tools mentioned.
Only those never admit, identify the next logical action
after this lesson that becomes goal.
If you can identify a real action, do not fake one.
Switch to reflection mode.
Uh, let me check in with you guys. Are you guys liking this?
Yes or no?
Is this good or what?
Now you guys know the secret,
so it's telling me pace this into open claw.
So let's go ahead and do this. Let's see what happens.
Okay, let's see what happens.
All right, here we go. Now guys, if you had gone back
and forth, back and forth, back and forth, back
and forth, back and forth with open claw,
it'd been like, ching,
Ching, ching, ching, ching, ching, ching ching.
And that's the reason why, uh, some
of you are paying too much money.
Does that make sense? Some
of you're paying way too much money.
You need to be arguing with cha GBT use open cloud
to execute and train.
Okay, this is gold saving this as a gold block framework.
But to actually generate one, I need the transcript
of lesson, how we create newsletters option.
You paste the transcript here, I use the browser
to access the lesson Vimeo id if it's linked.
Okay, so let's try this Vimeo thing again. Okay?
I'm gonna see if I can get it into there
until I get an update from G Um,
Um, Chad, actually you can now say use the token
instead. It should be there.
Okay, cool. You found the problem?
Yeah. Okay. Or did you just refresh it?
No, what we did was, instead of letting open Claw login,
we just did from our side
and gave it the token, that doesn't expire.
Oh, nice. Okay.
So I'm gonna tell it to go into that Vimeo folder.
That means we're gonna have the perfect demonstration at ag.
Alright, let's go do Pacino bot.
Look for the
folder Pacino bought.
All right, let's see. Let's see if G's a hero.
Let's see if G Money is a hero today.
All right, sorry guys, we're going over,
but this is exactly
what I would've been doing with my team today.
So remember, this is Shadow program.
Uh, I'm just a little bit more animated
with you guys today 'cause I'm starting to feel better.
Alright, so it is typing over here using the Vimeo token.
Look for the folder Pacino bot.
So I'm gonna tell it to go in there, grab one
of those videos, uh, transcribe it if it needs to,
and create a goal block
and place the goal block on the lesson.
Yeah. Now is the goal block gonna be perfect?
No, but let's try it. All right, so, got it.
Let me analyze and generate the goal block,
goal block analysis, how we create newsletters in 2.0.
The lesson explains the concept
and vision of the 2.0 system, not the execution.
Chat explicitly says, I'm gonna show you exactly how
to create these articles in future videos.
This is the why and what
before the how Extracted Elements Core Promise.
Understand how articles become the engine
of your 2.0 newsletter.
Dual purpose content that ranks on
Google and fills your newsletter.
Demonstrated outcome articles equals game changer.
Seven 30 formula, same domain.
Time to cut what was not shown, how
to create the articles goal block.
Okay, so, uh, this is the goal block analysis.
So now let's go into the actual goal block creation,
which is this part right here, I think.
Alright, so let's look at this Goal block
type planning and reflection.
Since execution comes later,
pushing action steps will be fabricating the right move is a
planning exercise that sets them up for success.
Okay, goal title, map your 2.0 newsletter strategy,
goal type planning exercise instructions.
Before you create your first article, you need
to understand what you're building towards.
This exercise connects the dots between your local market
and the 2.0 system.
Part one, audit your current newsletter. 10 minutes.
How long does it currently take
you to create one newsletter.
What percentage is link teasers versus custom content
via AI generated?
What work? What's working that you want to keep in the 30%?
And part two, identify your article opportunities.
Open a note and brainstorm 10 local topics.
You could write articles about recent events,
local institutions, new business,
restaurants, community happenings.
Part three, reflection in questions.
What searches are people in your city already doing
that no one is answering?
Which of your current newsletter elements would
you like to keep in the 30%?
If you could cut your newsletter content creation time
to 25%, what would you do?
Completion criteria listed. Okay, you ready for this?
Uh, everybody's gonna hate us.
You just made this homework
and you took the fun out of it.
Not only that, uh,
you didn't help me understand why this was
important and how incredible things are going
to be when I complete
this goal, this goal block.
Also keep it to a fifth grade level.
They have to have fun to continue.
Don't give them a
to do list.
A couple things to do is great.
All right, you guys see that?
Does everybody see that? Yeah.
I'll memorize it here in a minute.
You guys would not have liked that goal block right now.
Uh, I, I, I see everybody's yelling.
Make sure you save that skill.
Uh, what G has set up in here is, uh,
even if I don't save it, it is journaling everything
so it can go back and get it.
Okay, you're right. That was homework. Let me fix it.
Goal block version number two. Goal title.
See the bigger picture. Here's the deal.
You just learn something that changes everything.
Articles aren't just blog posts,
they're little traffic machines that work
for you 24 7 showing up on Google, bringing in subscribers
and filling your newsletters at the same time.
One piece of content, two jobs, way less work.
Before you move on, do this.
Grab your phone or a piece of paper.
Write down three things happening in your town
right now that people might Google.
That's it. Just three things.
A new restaurant, a road closure, something at the school.
These are your first articles waiting to happen. Why?
This matters. When you finish this course,
you'll have a newsletter that practically builds itself
and you'll be showing up on Google
where your neighbors are already searching.
That's how you become the go source in your community.
Three ideas. That's your goal. Let's go. You guys like it.
Make sure you tell them to comment
down below and get them excited
to move forward to the next lesson.
All right, there we go. Look at this here
guys, look at this here.
You liken this. That's my type
of goal block right there, right?
Alright, here we go. Goal title.
See the bigger picture, version three. Here's the deal.
You just learned something that changes everything.
Articles aren't just blog
posts, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
One piece of content, two jobs, way less work.
You're one thing. Think
of three things happening in your town right now.
New restaurant, road closure, local here. Something funny.
That's just it. Three ideas.
Drop your best one in the comments down below.
We wanna see what you come up with.
Plus, when you see what everyone else is right about,
you're gonna get even more ideas coming up.
Next, I'll show you how
to turn those ideas into real articles using the ai.
You do the heavy lifting. Yeah, don't do that.
Don't you start forecasting.
Don't you start forecasting, right? That screws us up.
You don't wanna do that, right?
Just ask them how excited they are.
What's this going to do for them?
Are they loving the course?
Just give them positive reinforcements.
All right, we're getting there. We're getting there.
But what I don't want it to do is say
that something's coming up in a lesson, guys,
and I don't even check the goal block.
And then people go to the lesson
and it's like, I thought the goal said it was gonna do this.
That was something completely different, right?
Okay, goal block, final. Oh, it's telling me this is final.
See the bigger picture? All right, all this is the same.
You're one thing. Think
of three things happening in your town right now
that people might Google new restaurant.
Just three ideas. Now, drop a comment down below.
How excited are you right now?
What's this gonna do for your newsletter?
Are you loving this so far? Good.
But, but
when you give the reinforcement,
make sure those statements are consistent
with what they just did.
Alright, we're getting close. We're getting close now.
I can tell it to make it longer.
I can tell it to make it shorter.
I can tell it to make it more exciting.
I can tell it to make it more serious.
Okay, so let's look just three ideas. Now. Drop a comment.
Did it click for you? Can you see how? There we go.
Can you see how one article does two jobs?
Now what's the first topic
you wanna write about in your town?
We wanna hear it. Boom. That's what I'm looking for, guys.
On a scale of one outta 10, does everybody see this?
You wanna know the secret? I just gave you the secret.
The reason why all these people are blowing up the comments
over here and everything else isn't the goal block.
It is the positive reinforcement that I leave you with.
That's what it is, guys. How is this feeling?
How, what's it gonna feel like
when you make your first sale?
How excited are you to set up your first autoresponder?
Do you guys see the power of the articles?
How many are you guys seeing this now?
That was the secret right there. That's the secret.
It's the end of the goal block.
It's always the end of the goal block, right?
It's always the end of the goal block where you wanna have
that positive reinforcement.
That is what's gonna blow up your engagement.
All right, memorize this booya.
You guys ready to go? See if it can create the goal
Block time in the chat.
Who wants to see if it can create this goal block?
All right, here, here's what we're gonna do.
Here's what we're gonna do. All right,
Let's do this from the start.
Create a course called, uh,
newsletters for Dummies.
Use that video as a lesson
and make sure this lesson has the goal block.
Can you do that? All right, so memory locked in. Boom.
Today's journal, whammo,
long-term memory dedicated workflow.
Won't work, won't forget this one. Fun, simple.
Fifth grade lesson. Statistic reinforcement. No homework.
I said, all right, let's do it from the start.
Create a course called Newsletters for Dummies.
Use the video as a lesson
and make sure this lesson has the goal block.
Can you do that? It gave me the heart.
Alright, so let's come over here.
Let's see, let's see what it can do, guys.
So we're gonna come over here
and we're going to see it create, oh, it already did it.
Newsletters for dummies. Hold on a minute.
So it created this one right here.
This one's here by default,
how we create newsletters in 2.0.
So it brought in how we create newsletters in 2.0.
Learn the game changing 70 30 system
that cuts your newsletter time
to a quarter of what it used to be.
This one's a little bit longer.
It could be longer in my opinion. We'll put, we'll fix that.
But now let's come over here.
We got the video, how we create newsletters. Boom.
Tag the video. URL. Now, moment of truth.
Let's come over here and see if it figured out without any
training, how to create the freaking goal block.
I don't know how it could have done that.
Newsletters for Dummies. Uh, hold on.
It did it, it freaking did it.
The only thing it didn't do.
Okay, now, uh, it's gonna have to work on the format.
Let me ask you to, it could fit. So, uh, hold on a second.
It might not have the end point to do this.
We're gonna find out guys.
But it, it created the goal block.
It created, it created a freaking goal block.
Hold on a second. Can you tie, hold on a second.
You have to tie the goal
block to the lesson.
Also, can you do better
on the formatting of the goal block?
I didn't even, let's see. It was half.
You have to tie. Okay, hold on a second.
Let's come back over here and let's see what it does.
It's doing it, guys. This, this course was not here.
Are you guys seeing this? This
course was not here a minute ago.
All right, so let's see what it does.
Let me check what Phil's tie it properly.
New goal created HTML, formatting lesson ID linked
Add to comment enabled.
Our goal is still there. You may
wanna delete the one manually.
Can you check if it's showing up on the lesson now?
If not, let me know what's missing. All
right, let's go check it out.
I'm liking this guys.
I am actually kind of freaked out over
what I'm seeing, believe it or not.
Alright, so, uh, the same lesson still there.
Okay, gamification. Let's go over here.
Newsletter for Dummies goals.
Uh, it still has not tied it to the lesson.
If it did, it would be, oh wait, it did,
it did tie it to the lesson.
Hold on a second. I was wrong. It is tied to the lesson.
It did tie it to the lesson.
Okay, did it do anything with the format?
Oh, look at
that guys, look at this.
It tied it to the lesson. It cleaned up the format.
Holy crap. Are you guys seeing this right now?
Who is seeing this? You're seeing this real time now.
Watch this. Watch this. Oh, this is getting good.
This is getting really, really good.
Alright, let's come back over here now
and let's go like this.
By default, I want you
to assign it, assign it 10 points.
That's what I was looking at. It was assigned to the lesson.
Look at this guys. Oh, dude, I'm gonna tell you right now.
This is getting freaky. This is getting freaky.
Is there anybody freaking out over this right now?
This is insane.
This is next thing you know,
Pacino's gonna go on a date with my girl.
Oh, my girl's already liking Pacino.
Let me tell you something. All right, girl.
6, 6, 5, 10 points assigned.
Alright, let's go check this out.
So if I reload it now, let's go look inside of here.
Newsletter for dummies. Goals, point badge.
There it is right there, guys. Look at that. Look at that.
Holy crap. And it assigned at the points. Okay?
It needs to create the user input field.
We could even have it add it to the community.
Okay, so let's tell it to do that.
I always create the user input field.
Guys, on a scale of one out of a hundred,
how excited are you with what you're seeing right now?
How excited are you?
All my superpowers just went out the door, guys.
I'm the only one that's been able
to create courses like this for the last 15 years.
And every single one of you are now at my level.
Every single one of you can do what I've been doing.
Look at this. Done.
Goal six, six with all the default 10 points, user input,
field, add to comment.
HTML formatted. Are you serious right now?
So let's reload this. Let's come over here.
Let's look at it again. Newsletters for dummies, goals.
It's gonna be one of these bad boys. Let's see.
Let's come down to the bottom 10 points.
Create user input, field add to comments.
It did it, it freaking did it guys.
I I am shocked at what I'm seeing.
I am shocked. Memorize it.
Hannah, what are your thoughts? Talk to me.
What are your thoughts?
I'm mind blown right now. Chad,
Nick, what are your thoughts?
Yeah, it's pretty cool. I definitely, uh, awesome,
awesome usage right here.
You are paying an employee right now
to do this manually every single day.
Nick, do you know that?
Every single day. Every single day.
Alright, moment of truth, guys,
this is a soundbite that I want.
Let me just check in with g. G.
Is the OAuth good or is the, uh, key? Good?
Yeah, it's all good.
Here we go guys. This is a soundbite.
Okay, so I'm gonna come over here
and I'm gonna grab this folder.
Okay? So I'm gonna go back to, uh,
my burger.
All right, Pacino bot, here we go. You ready for this?
So the folder is Pacino bot,
and we are going to create a course called,
uh, compete Up.
All right, let's just go ahead and do this.
Okay, here we go. I'm gonna turn this off for a minute.
Watch this. Let's see if we can get all
the way to the finish line.
Okay, I'm actually, I'm kind of nervous with this one.
All right, let's see. Let's don't make me my words.
All right, hold on a minute. Uh, not now.
Okay, so there we go. Hey, Pacino.
Uh, we need to start building this course
and, uh, I want to go all in with this, right?
So, uh, I want you to complete the course.
It's gonna be called Compete Up. Uh, go ahead and go ahead.
Um, hold on a second. That's not a good sound bite.
Skip that, skip that, skip that. Skip that.
Alright, let's try this again.
All right, Pacino, we need to create this course.
Uh, I want to call it compete Up.
The folder on Vimeo, uh, is called Pacino Bot.
And I want you to go ahead
and, uh, create the course, start creating the lessons.
Uh, do what we usually do, and then go ahead
and, uh, create a goal block for each lesson.
Does that make sense? Alright.
Not very detailed, but let's see what happens.
Nick, can you see yourself doing that every day?
I, I see someone doing it worse every day.
Alright, let's see what happens.
So I sent in an audio, right?
You guys, how many of you have set up your audios already?
Has everybody gone through the onboarding process
and set up your audios?
All right. It's typing. It's typing.
So we asked it to create a course call Compete up, okay?
Uh, and then we gave it, uh, the folder in Vimeo,
and it's called Pacino Bot, right?
So let's see what happens.
Come on, baby, don't you let me
down, don't you let me down.
So it's gonna access through the Vimeo API,
it's gonna access through the course route API
and let's see what happens.
We got this bad boy all trained,
and then, uh, are you guys interested in
acquiring this skill from us?
By the way, does anybody want this skill?
Anybody want this skill? Yeah.
How many of you now believe
that this is absolutely the future?
Let me grab a screenshot of that while we're waiting
'cause uh, it doesn't come up in the recording.
Yep, a hundred percent. All right. Come on baby.
It's typing. It's typing, it's typing, it's typing.
Guys, everybody thought I was crazy when I said this is
going to replace every manual task
that we are doing in our business.
Every manual task that Nick is doing in his business, right?
I'm telling you right now,
you guys should be out there selling this thing.
You should be looking at businesses, going
to them saying, Hey, you know what?
We can automate your whole entire business.
'cause this will become the norm after a while
and people won't even think of it anymore.
Just like Chad. GPT was exciting when it came out.
Remember that actually Nick was the first person on the
planet, uh, to tell me about Chad, GPT.
He was, you were like one of the first a hundred people
to know on the planet, right?
Nick, you were involved in that.
Um, you were involved in that whole thing, weren't you?
Yeah, I had access to GPT before it had API.
So it's pretty cool.
Yeah. Okay, got it.
Creating the course, compete up from the Pacino,
bought Vimeo folder with lessons and goal blocks for each.
Let me check my course brow skill
and check for any prior context.
Holy smokes. Found context.
Let me get more details on the goal block workflow. Got it.
Let me journal the plan. Start executing. Course created.
Let me fix a Vimeo, API call
and get the full course found three videos.
Let me get the transcripts and create the lessons.
The goal blocks. Got the transcripts now.
Creating lessons than goal blocks, lessons created.
Now getting lesson ideas, creating the goal blocks.
Let me try a different approach. I'll create the goals using
estimate lesson ideas based on the pattern.
All done. Let me update the journal. Done.
Course number one. Three lessons from the Pacino bot folder.
Tour the dashboard, understanding the rewards library,
reading statistics, goal blocks, 10 point each dashboard,
mastery prize versus rewards.
Stat matters. All videos tagged complete up.
Are you serious? Are you freaking serious right now?
Did you guys see that? Did you see that?
Type in the chat here. Let me know if you saw that.
So let's come over here. There is no course here.
Let's come over here. Let's refresh this thing.
All I did was give it a Vimeo folder
and boom, here is the course.
Four lessons in there. The first one's by default.
That's okay. Alright, so first let's go look at the course.
Alright, let's look at the course first.
Let's see what it created. Let's come over here.
Let's click here. And what do we got?
Compete up courses built from the Pacino Vimeo folder.
Alright, it needs to do better on
the description, but that's okay.
We'll give it the pass on that. Let's come over here.
Let's edit these lessons. Alright, there's the video.
There's a video. There's a video. Pull it from Vimeo.
Okay, let's go ahead and look at this here.
Tour the dashboard. Learn to navigate your dashboard
after contest completed.
Un publish. See impressions, points,
and how to manage your contest.
Guys, this software's super, super old.
I don't even know what that means, but let's come over here.
Let's look at this Pacino bot. There it is.
And let's edit it there. Boom. It pulled in the video.
It's got the tag, it's got the Vimeo URL Moment of truth.
Did it go and create the goal blocks, right?
Did it create the goal blocks? Gamification.
Let's come down here. Let's go over here. Boom.
Let's click here. Goals three goals.
Let's look at these goals. Tour the dashboard.
Let's open this up. Look at this here.
Look at the formatting. There's the goal. Here's the deal.
Just learn how to navigate your dashboard.
Like a pro active contest.
Completed, unpublished, you know where everything lives.
Now the dashboard is your command center. Impressions.
Tell you who's looking points,
tell you who's engaged, your one thing.
Log into your dashboard, find one contest or complete one.
If you haven't yet, copy the link below. Paste it somewhere.
You'll see it. Drop a comment down below.
Did the dashboard layout click for you?
What's the first contest you're planning to run?
Uh, 10 points. Create user field. Uh, add to comments.
Oh my God, it did it, it did it
guys, it did it.
Do, do you understand what this means?
I'm shocked. That probably means Nick,
that you can have a hundred videos in a Vimeo folder
that you've shot or you've created with AI or whatever else.
And you can just be an In-N-Out burger
and you can send it a message saying, Hey, it's time
to go build another course.
And it does it. I'm speechless guys.
I I am speechless.
Is there anybody else here who has some thoughts on this?
Guys type the come on, talk to me here.
Who has some thoughts?
Thi this is business changing man. This changes everything.
I'm lost for words too, Martin. I'm lost for words too.
So gee, how do we package that up and give it to 'em?
Is anybody wanting that? Is there anybody wanting that?
How, how, how do we package that up and give it to 'em?
Gee, I'm telling you right now guys,
here's the opportunity, man.
You go find those API docs, you do everything
that I've been trained you how to do.
You start shooting videos all over your wall.
You start doing the magic I just did today.
You go build a massive audience.
Man, there's so many APIs out there, not just ours.
We've already tied into name cheap.
We've already tied into Vimeo, we've already tied into Zoom.
There's so many we could tie into 11 labs.
We can tie into Hagen.
My God, it's incredible what we can do.
Incredible. Let me check in with G. Are you there G?
Yeah, I'm here. Can you package
that up so we can give it to him?
Yeah. So once we have the skill ready, I'll give that
g file on the WhatsApp room probably.
And then you can, you guys can install Dolly.
Okay, we'll give it to you guys on WhatsApp.
I'll, I'll perfect that long description there, okay?
And make sure that it brings in the course description.
Um, and then we'll see if we can find a way
to tie it into some API that will uh, bring in the image.
'cause it should be talking to Dolly. It should or GBT.
It should be creating that image for you.
Okay guys, it will do everything.
What blows my mind is I kind of thought
that it would do one video,
take five minutes, create the lesson.
Did you guys see that? It just went and grabbed them all?
It went bubu
Done all of them.
All of 'em. I I, I am, I am shocked.
So, uh, look, that was a big task.
A lot of people thought that we were
not gonna be able to do it.
Uh, but guys, we did it. We absolutely did it.
So here's what I'm gonna do. I'm gonna,
I'm gonna meet you halfway today
because it took a little bit longer than I thought.
Uh, but I do wanna give this to you.
So tomorrow you guys are gonna build an app live on the call
and you're gonna deploy it.
Uh, it's gonna go, uh, into the repository.
You're gonna be able to access it, uh,
on your computer, okay?
You're gonna, you open up a URL,
you're gonna be able to actually see it.
Alright? We're gonna do that tomorrow.
But I wanted to give you guys this prompt
that I created for you right here.
This command, this is called the second brain mode.
Build and maintain my second brain.
So the objective, create a structured knowledge system
as a next J app that, uh,
or next JS app that feels like a mix of a cian and linear.
It should display a sidebar list of documents,
render clean markdown documents, support search tabs,
allow link research between documents.
Auto read from a folder called second brain.
What the heck does that mean? Don't worry about it.
So from now on, create documents
for important concepts, systems and decisions.
Create structured notes for strategies and builds.
Generate a daily journal
and entry summarizing key discussions.
What was built? Important insights. Next steps.
Store everything in my second brain. Be proactive.
There's that word, guys. Be proactive.
Don't wait to be told what to document.
Rules never deploy automatically.
Uh, never overwrite without versioning.
Use poll requests for structural changes.
Always link related documents when
relevant default behavior.
If it matters, document it.
Would you guys like to have this?
I will add this to your Google doc,
but just make sure that you guys are
deploying these things in the timely
fashion that we're giving it to you.
Would anybody like to have this?
We went back and forth on this one back and forth.
We've already gone and tested it.
You're just gonna go ahead and paste this command, uh,
inside of, uh, your open claw
and it will work perfectly.
All right. So let me see if I can find that.
I'll go ahead and put it down here. Uh, right here.
We'll say insert line. Okay, here you go.
Here is your second brain.
All right, let's make sure, uh,
open cloth, second brain mode.
Okay, there you go. It is on your sheet.
So now you have your API skill builder, right?
That's what we use today with course routes.
Uh, you have the open claw autonomous operator directive.
This is where it is now, uh, yeah, going not,
it's going from reactive to proactive.
And now you have the open cloth, second brain mode.
And I'm gonna keep giving you guys these,
so make sure you guys keep up with it
and feed it when I tell you to.
Alright? Does that make sense?
Is it good?
Uh, yes.
I will do that too, Chris. I don't have it yet.
We went over a little bit today.
Um, but I, I wanted, I just wanted to get
to the finish line on that thing, guys.
Okay, so Hannah just posted the Google doc there.
Guys, let me just ask one more time
on a question of one outta 10.
You guys getting a lot of value on the workshop? Is it good?
I'm sorry for my voice. I'm sorry. Being sick.
But guys, I I'm telling you man,
this stuff's gonna change your life.
Opportunity. Timing is everything with this right now.
Nobody except us is doing this.
Nobody, nobody, nobody, nobody.
Alright, and then we will go
and, uh, we will give you guys, uh, the,
the training that we did today.
We, we will give you that actual skill.
You won't have to do anything like I did today, right?
I'll, I'll get off my hype train and I'll sit down
and I'll make sure it has everything perfect
before we give it to you.
We'll find a way to get the logo in and there you go.
We'll get the replay in there
and everything else, guys, take action
with the things we're telling you.
Please, please, please, please, please, please,
this is gonna change everything for you.
Alright? Uh, gee, thank you so much for your help today.
Thanks for fixing that. API uh, lemme just make sure that,
uh, there's no other comments over here.
Uh, try singers throat spray. I will try it.
Uh, not seeing open cloth. Second brain.
I'll get it there, Sherry, if I
didn't save it, I'll get it there.
Uh, maybe Hannah can help me with that.
Guys, thank you so much.
I'm gonna go take my medicine, get on with Nick, see
how we can automate this in his business.
Uh, and everybody else. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
We'll get the replay. See you guys tomorrow. Bye-bye.